if that's the country you want you know
who to vote for you must keep everyone
in a constant state of fear you've got
to keep everyone looking Every Which Way
and people are coming to get them and
all that good stuff so let's go to
Whoopi the day before on The View what's
she really afraid of well Trump might
come back and take out the journalists
and the
gays I'm here to say it's ours to lose
it is this country this is what it's all
about either you want it to work forward
thinking you want everybody to have the
ability to say how they feel what they
want to move forward or you don't or you
want somebody who says I'm going to be
on day one I'm going to be a dictator
who says it to you tells you I'm going
put you people away I'm going to take
all the journalists I'm going take all
the gay folks I'm going to move you all
around and disappear you if that's the
country you want you know who to vote
for if that's not if that's not the
country you want you have to make a
decision that's what wants that's what
still in a
primary may they may like that but the I
believe the people of the United States
will make themselves very clear because
people keep telling them what they're
doing media keeps saying this is what
you're doing I see you I see that face
you guys from your lips to God we'll be
right thank God nobody at that table's a
journalist or they might have something
to worry about uh as for the gays he's
going to take the gay folks first he has
not said that I'm going to come in in
day one I'm going to take the
journalists and the gays also you can't
do that you just because you're in the
office of the presidency you can't just
imagine suddenly do whatever you want we
still do have some vestage of a
functioning government and separation of
powers and all those things you can't
just Round Up journalists and all that
stuff right is some of his rhetoric over
the top of course it
is